hillary clinton have you heard about
this lady her husband was the former
governor of arkansas he became president
then she became a senator from New York
then she became Secretary of State
national wrote a book called hard
choices and
she was interviewed by Diane Sawyer on
ABC news
and had some interesting things to say
about the clintons wife post
presidency it has been reported you've
made five million
making speeches the president made more
than 100
million dollars well if
if you you have no reason to remember
but we came out at the white house
not only dead broke but in dept we had
no money when we got there
and we struggle to you know piece
together the resources for
mortgages for houses for childhood
education
you know it was not easy they had no
money when they got there I didn't know
that and then
not only dead broke but in get when they
left
at max we're watching this before we
start a new you picked up on
an interesting added s add yeah I
mention makes it sound like her life was
really hard having multiple houses
yeah it was poor whole I can't believe
that they left a while
is a is that true were actually
according to open secret in 2000 when
the Clintons left the white house they
did network at -10 million dollars
but you could only get to a net worth at
-10 in doubt if you would access
two tons of money before that so for her
to imply that somehow they were dead
broke or really in debt knowing how much
money
with about to come in the 100 million
bucks and play
feel like there are there are levels
above insanely recchia
okay and more breed will probably never
be in this boat but I
and get where he's coming from no-no
okay you're right I threw it all
possible but I no I i mean i think
yet on there's a will there's a little
bit disingenuous disingenuousness going
on here
but at the same time yet they had to pay
a lot a legal fees for all that
whitewater crap in all the other sort of
football should accusations got her loom
over the course of the years
their daughter put their school yes they
have multiple houses I'm not
no one is thinking that these people or
you know get a good one food stamps or
G under said the idea genuine poverty
but
I don't begrudge them the ability to
make money making speeches i mean
I you know I grew what we'll get to that
part I don't think anyone regret is them
the chance
that to make money by the way bill
clinton as for president get the
you know yearly the sellers this typing
up like a hundred twenty thousand
which is still more than most people
make on top about the money for speeches
and all that
the but they are too let's talk about
then what happened after so then
Hillary time do this first we had to pay
off our debts
which was you know you had that make
double the money because I've obviously
taxes and pay off the debts and
guest houses and take care of family
members but do you think americans can
understand five times
the median income in this country for
months
speech well let me put it this way I
thought
making speeches for money was a much
better thing than getting connected with
any
one group or company as so many people
who leave public life do
outcome so much better than everyone
else in public life because not good not
only did
should take money from one giant
companies take money pretty much
from everybody should take a lot of
money from Goldman Sachs defend her go
alright well how many seconds before
Eric Cantor becomes a lobbyist or II
depending on how much you're all going
door is for these people to go back
and like she'll for you know big
armament or performer wherever else so I
you know I will please give the point I
did you expect you
you get that money retreat is your least
singing for your supper at the
great supper obviously but you're not in
anybody's pocket
you know with so many perot the shins
are II look I'm OK
think she did anyone when she takes five
hundred thousand pretty speeches to
I'm court after I'm nothing the clintons
are pure and perfect or or anything else
but I'm just saying
I think we're kinda pop piling on for a
relatively non gross wave being a former
politician
also you know based on what other people
are doing yeah I've seen clinton speak
on behalf of global
Clinton Global Initiative and I you know
i'm always you know completely inspired
by
by him in the work that they're doing in
I don't begrudge them anything yeah but
this out to me this is about a great
because I agree with you they have to
make money somehow people pay them for
the speeches that's fine I was
you know we are a capitalistic society
it's more the idea that she's framing it
as if they struggled
which it so I do think they'd ever not
been able to get
since he's been president or even
probably a little bit before the you
think there's
anything they've ever wanted that they
haven't been able to get have a
ever not been able to go to a restaurant
but they wanted to go to or buy a car
that they wanted or or anything
with the struggle it's not the writer
but maybe the question here's why is
dying for your framing it like
oh how dare you make this much money or
go ask George W Bush question go ask
you know any former senator who is now
you know showing from Northrop Grumman
that question wanna know why
when he returned when hillary does it
certainly is the worst thing ever
well I totally hear that and listen I
would give dick cheney as much shit for
you know helping Halliburton get
contracts which I'm in the back
sorry I'm just giving them all equal if
they let they really all about there
might be a battle I nominate from The
Dark Knight Rises were talking about
superhero movies over and I didn't even
go broke like the rest of us
yeah I don't know how much could I ever
getting ten million dollars that would
be birch really impossible
this is bridges 1 percent lemme style
bankruptcy
yeah which is that if somebody is
willing to loan you 10 million and
you're able to pay back a member
yeah a pretty good data problems white
why did the people are so afraid of
being proud of success cuz I think that
that goes to what you're saying about
Diane Sawyer's question
there is this this idea that everyone
has to be struggling all the time I'll
people who are running for president me
to come off as
relate a bull and you know well singer
is running for Prime II
you know I'm here big things I don't
know but you know I I think
she's this is clearly part of the
narrative above you know just plain
folks which
they have work to a certain extent or
other ever since leaving arkansas
yeah what do we do you think we have
this like weird implicit shame about
success in this country
arm you know I if we do it's sad
you know I I like to think that we
should you know be proud people hold
people's examples on to become
successful for
noble causes you know and I think it's
important to see them as reliable but I
think that their
their necessity for that has passed you
know that's what got him into office
yeah arm way I mean I you know again I i
think that
that the success that they've had post
post presidency i think is warranted
you know alright well I think what we
learn here is that I will not be voting
for Hillary I think a lot though will be
voting for a will
baby I rode with a ready answer and Max
possibly St a possibility a probable
okay